a bit up duty Romeo and Juliet are
moving to a whole new garden all clear
not quite perfect but it's ours think of
all the adventures were gonna have
oh man Kady that is just are you done
Cousy humans coming purges everyone they
were supposed to live happily ever after
but when their world is in danger
Julia the gnomes the roeckl there's only
one known to call and Sherlock knows
sworn protector of garden gnomes you
mean except for the one you literally
just broke danger of the director of
Kung Fu Panda
we can't anyone hear this but they're
going to smash us all tomorrow night or
an adventure we have to get across that
River you'll need a ship no [ __ ]
Sherlock
you've got a great unknown our next clue
is in the park get directions quickly
this follow the blue line on the ground
until you find the giant red boy Emily
block - Attila tear poor mary j blige
and Johnny Depp with original music by
Elton John and Bernie Taupin they have
to go him to come out let's go - forward
hold hold
- give me I've never been the back end
of a squirrel before
Sherlock knows that's not how a squirrel
six it's behind mankini can you
demonstrate unduly you see yes you're
acting like a rear end
you